[Applause]
what advice do you have for like recent
college graduates
that are looking to invest in cryptos
like how should i diversify my portfolio
i i think it's the same thing right of
like when you're young
here's a really interesting concept
where um if i said to you
are you wealthy most people would think
in terms of dollars right
or like financial assets uh if i said to
you
uh would you switch lies with warren
buffett
and you get all of his 90 plus billion
dollars but you got to be 94. would you
do it no
no right so actually the more valuable
asset is time
not dollars right you can't buy more
time right so there's a whole concept
like time billionaire
so a million seconds is about seven days
or i'm sorry
11 days right time for a billion seconds
is 31 years
so at 24 you probably got 2 billion
seconds left in your life
losers
so two billion seconds the the greatest
advantage you have is that you've got
literally got
you know 15 years uh more than he does
in terms of financial markets so like
let compounding work for you
the thing that we haven't talked about
is bitcoin has grown 200 compound annual
growth rate for 10 years 10 11 12 years
whatever it's been
right so like if you start to dollar
cost average now you just constantly
keep doing that over time
that's true of every financial asset and
i think that the the thing that young
people
always do as a mistake and i did the
same thing was like you just want to be
rich today you're like yo i want to be
rich today what can i do like what's the
you know zero or hero type thing to do
but it's actually not the way that
people build wealth right
jeff bezos didn't build his wealth over
a year he's been only doing this for 30
years right
and the same thing with all these other
people and so it's like okay cool
set a goal let's say when i'm 30. you
got six years all right i want to have a
million dollars when i'm sick
in six years cool do the math just back
into it
all right if i invest 20 bucks every
week and it compounds at 10
a year for six years what do i have okay
that's not a million dollars all right
go back
and you just start to play with the
numbers and you just come up with like
yo i should put a thousand dollars in
the market and i don't know what exact
numbers are about a thousand dollars i
should invest every single week
and if it grows at ten percent a year
then i have a million dollars in six
years
okay now how do i get a thousand dollars
a week to invest right you just back
into it and
what i think ends up happening is like
we live in this weird world where
everyone looks at the end result but
they don't back into the plan
and so it's like you ever heard these
people that are like yo everyone's like
got the dream but not the plan
but the plan is actually what gets you
there and so the single best thing i've
ever done
and i'm not gonna go into details before
you ask is uh i basically started to
create
um like a net worth calculator right and
so i literally use an exp
excel spreadsheet every month i just
update it and you can literally watch
the numbers move and it's not because i
give a [ __ ] like what you know if it
goes up down whatever like in the short
term but it's just i know
yo is there more money in my bank
account this month or last month right
did the stocks that i own which are zero
go up or down
right is the real estate is this like
all this stuff and so you start to track
it and it goes back to this
uh whole idea of like what you measure
you'll move
and so like if i said to you right now
what are you worth like you'll start
trying to calculate you know hey here's
what i own here's this here's whatever
but if all of a sudden i said to you
cool you got to grow 10 between this
month and next month
all right then you start thinking like
how do i do that and i think that's like
the biggest thing is
it's the like psychological concept of
financial
planning but not in the sense of like yo
i want to diversify 60 40 in bonds and
all this [ __ ]
it's like yo i have a number that i
think is really important
and i have a timeline on which i want to
hit that number so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to back into from where i
am today to that number what do i have
to do
and then you'll know i'm either tracking
to it or i'm not and if you're not
tracking to it like
go do something else like it's not
working do something else i think that's
the key to this whole thing
but people are just like yo uh i want to
be a millionaire
okay how are you going to do it um we
get a million dollars like
not going to happen right thank you
anthony yeah shoes
it's uh it's what you say i like your
shoes
those shoes suck i'm team adams.com
dude who's adam dude yo listen you want
to know the adam story listen you ready
here's that here's the adam's story yeah
you can feel like a [ __ ] yeah
if it's anything like tom he gives the
shoes to the kids
what's up with these white boys just
making sneakers dude so by the [ __ ]
sneakers the black guys made cool it's
that simple
what's this so they're both packaging on
the table they're from pakistan
[Music]
these guys are trying to outlaw bitcoin
dude so uh welcome sieger
fiat adam is for the bomb india should
drop on that
so welcome sieger basically grew up in
pakistan and they
wanted to get out so it's great like six
years ago seven years ago whatever they
don't even know english
right yeah basically come in they get
into y combinator in uh
san francisco and they're working on a
different shoe company and then there's
like yo the only way out of this place
is we got to build a company so they end
up building this company which are these
shoes
they got a co-founder of reddit alexis
ohani in 776. like all these
folks who all backed them and basically
what ends up happening is they went and
they convinced tech people that the most
comfortable shoes in the world yeah as
soon as that happened then what happens
next then the artistic people
then just keep going like that no it
hasn't it hasn't kept going i see how
it's pockets it's
just looks like you're wearing burqas
actually now
that's the thing i'm gonna give your
cell phone number they're coming for you
but that's the thing only tech people
wear these things nobody else wears do
you want to know what else tech people
do
what do they do they use facebook first
they're on clubhouse they're like
basically they know all the trends
before anybody else they're not fashion
nah they don't they don't get no [ __ ]
first
right all the tech people are just
coming to miami like how do i get into
car bone
you know what i mean is they're nerds
how do you know they're asking are they
asking you standing outside and like
they are asking can you get me a car but
i'm like i'm like in the bitcoin
it's a little knowledge swap there's a
knowledge swap but no we can't act like
they understand if you want to go to
cardboard
you just get in touch with andrew
exactly we got this
dove no but the the thing with tech
people is they don't understand anything
that like um
what is it called hardware like that's
what happened with google with the
glasses like google just do the nerd
[ __ ] don't
make glasses because we're not gonna
wear your nerd things because you don't
know what looks cool yeah the glasses
was a little weird anything they
try to do is physical doesn't work you
think the apple car is gonna work though
right of course apple car works
cause apple's not nerds bro
you